so you started out in a different
environment in public radio
uh and so how was that experience for
you i guess that was relatively early in
your career
yeah i started i you know right after
college i
had a crisis of identity and i didn't
know what i was going to do so i started
all first in
and working as a financial advisor for
for morgan stanley dean witter and um it
was actually kind of during that
miserable commute around the dc
beltway i discovered public radio and
over
a number of years i kind of set my
sights on public radio because i
realized that's really what i
wanted to be doing i just loved the
craft of it and i loved
the way that they told stories i'd never
had a desire to go into tv
and i also didn't really do internships
through college because i was you know
working full-time and just
a little bit lost in general so it
wasn't until after a while after college
i discovered npr
and set my sights and i started at npr
in 2002 and um
loved every day from from the you know
first minute i was there
so so you were attracted to npr and i
have to say when i was out there
campaigning around the country npr was
like its own
oasis of news like there were folks that
listened to it
the local npr stations
uh seemed very free they were very pure
you'd go in
and they had listeners who really wanted
a particular
version of both the news and the
listening experience
uh you were attracted to that and it
sounds like you were there from 2002 to
2013
more or less i mean you were doing some
other stuff but it was all
uh public radio directed is that right
it's like 11 years or so
yes that's correct yeah um and
yeah i mean i just this morning i was
listening i listened
to kqed frequently which is a san
francisco station and you know it's
it's such a you know pleasure because
the you know the local
um public affairs program forum they
were they covered
um the local um uh drug overdose
epidemic and how it's gotten worse
through the pandemic and then they moved
on to
um the the new coveted vaccines for
another 30 minutes and it's this long
in-depth conversation and things that i
didn't even know i needed to know but
yeah i mean it's it's it's just so much
more and so
such better information that you can get
yeah and npr is supported
through um public funding um though
though npr now has
so many listeners and sponsors and
advertisers that
it's largely self-sustaining and a lot
of people have also donated to it
um so it's like a combination um
and then you wound up at msnbc which
uh it seemed like your
experience was a bit different uh how
was the experience
i kind of came into it with the attitude
i mean we knew that
everything was kind of you know we knew
that rating i knew that ratings
um played a part in our daily lives
i didn't understand the extent of it and
i thought
coming in i could bring my skills that i
had
in public radio and part of that is
really trying to find new and
interesting and compelling
stories and angles and voices and they
would
want to you know they would be they
would welcome that because
in my mind i felt like one of my big
criticisms of
cable news coming into it was the
repetition it was just i just felt like
it was
you know you're watching the same five
or six stories kind of all day
throughout the day so um i thought that
that was an opportunity for me
to come in and you know make things
better
right um so i i struggled with that for
a
few years um i really i you know i tried
different types of stories and kind of i
strengthened my pitches and
realized okay they might not listen to
me the first time but i'll keep coming
back and you know trying to
to sell this other idea or strengthen my
argument maybe they don't
you know maybe it's not intuitive why
something is a good idea
and over time i you know i i
got a little bit frustrated but um then
started to get
at the same time a little bit of
seniority so i was more involved in the
planning meetings you know with the
senior producer
and the executive producer and or the
senior producers
there was usually more than one and at
that point i
realized the extent that they really
that the ratings really drove all of the
decisions
and it was it was it's down to you know
it's the first thing out of their mouths
as soon as you throw out an idea and
they don't necessarily talk that way
in the wider editorial meetings with the
full staff
it really was in this the smaller
planning meetings
you know it's the first thing out of
their mouths like how things rated the
night before how
they thought something did and those
those ratings are broken down by quarter
hours so they have a pretty good
understanding of what did well and what
didn't do well
and so they will track the topics of
course
and they'll track the guests you know so
if you know if the guest does well
or if regress guest rates well or not
they really
rely on that for
almost every decision so um it
that's it wasn't until the last few
years
when the reality um became
you know pretty stark to me and then you
know i wasn't gonna be able to fight
that fight
you know there wasn't you know these
people are just doing their jobs
and it's all out of their hands it's out
of lawrence's hands it's out of phil
griffin's hands
it's it's at a higher way higher pay
level um
where that where the problems are you
know one of the things you said was that
look these are good people
uh you know trying to do good work but
uh they're put in a position where their
job does not necessarily produce the
kind of journalism you'd want it to
which is something i completely get
and empathize with is that if you put
people in a position where their
incentives are all steering them one
direction you kind of expect them to
end up uh listening to those incentives
you know it's like
and if you don't listen to those
incentives and let's say your ratings
underperform
uh consistently then someone's going to
make a change and so like that's the
the race you're always running uh
like were there other people that ever
expressed any misgiving maybe someone
else from like a similar background as
you
yes um those conversations didn't happen
very often but
over the last year or two when i was
there there were times when i would have
conversations in private with other
producers
and um certainly they
you know with a couple of people um
they said i think we're making things
worse
you know um some seem to think that
yeah what we're doing here is probably
benefiting trump and would help him get
elected again
the person who said we are a cancer that
is that's one of those conversations it
was somebody
in the building um uh
and has been in the the business a long
time so
um but it wasn't something that people
talked about in the open
you know it wasn't until i went in and
sat down like kind of one-on-one with
them
um otherwise that the the notion that
ratings drive everything it's just
it's really built into the process and
it's it's
of course you know that's just that's
just what you do and
you know most of those people came up
through
the commercial tv system somehow and i
obviously have a public radio background
and
none of the editorial decisions i ever
made before were based on
how it would rate or how big of an
audience we thought we would have i mean
we always wanted a big audience but you
know you hope that you know what you're
doing is compelling enough to hold
people's attention um but that's not
what
determines those decisions and so for me
you know it was like it really raked
against my
nerves every time i heard them say
something like you know that's not going
to rain
when it's something that i knew would be
a good topic some of the decisions were
made out of ideological
reasons um but it also
kind of drives the division that that
we're seeing and the polarization in
this
in the country so they might be pumping
up you know
um ideas that are exciting to some
people but then there was never you know
they don't get excited about the
you know someone with a more nuanced or
moderate take on things
and um so that that just kind of keeps
driving
everybody apart and there's you know you
know there's no
sense that okay there is some benefit to
compromise
every now and then i just i know that
that's not a popular idea right now
because we've gotten so far away from
that but
um you know the the in my sense is
that it just when you
stand back and look at the totality of
you know all the different ways that the
financial incentives affect
the content it's just driving us down
the wrong path and it's only getting
worse
the way that i see it you drew a couple
of examples
in your resignation letter which i
recommend that everyone
find and read because i just thought it
was so brave and
incisive and true
so thank you for it and i'm a huge
admirer of yours you did something
out of principle that the vast vast
majority of people
don't ever do and if enough people did
what you did we might actually have a
chance
and i don't mean just in media though
the media is a significant part of this
but
you know in in many different
environments where your financial
incentives are
to uh just pretend it's okay
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode